hello and welcome to my Django tutorial
Django
but no not named after that good movie
though actually Django gets his name
from jazz guitarist Django Reinhardt
what this isn't a music tutorial either
instead we're here to talk about the
Django web framework for Python cool so
what's that mean a web framework is just
like some pre-built functionality for
the purpose of running a website as it
stands like Python you can't just make a
website with Python like you can with
like say PHP where PHP is like already
up there on the server and PHP is almost
a bit of a web framework itself so to
get Python up onto um you know a web
server and then also to start having it
display stuff as you would expect for
like a website coding language some
coding is required first so this is what
Django really does for you and it takes
even a few more steps
by making specific templates and
back-end functionality for all kinds of
things like forums and blogs and
whatever um kind of in my mind the way I
think of it as like a really really
toned down WordPress right you're given
a bunch of templates to work off of and
you can customize it a lot and probably
easier than you can with something like
WordPress there are other web frameworks
Django isn't the only web framework for
Python it just happens to be the most
popular one the other ones that I can
think of right now like there's a rock
there's web two pi and then there's
flask and then there's a few others in
terms of ease and light-weighted nough
say actually flask is probably the most
basic and lightweight one out there but
it just doesn't come with like all the
stuff that Django comes with it you're
gonna have to code your own stuff it's
it really is starting with a blank slate
it just makes it it just comes with a
couple of easy ways to
put it up on a website but everything
you've got to build yourself and so that
kind of leads us into Django and their
philosophy and really the Python
philosophy you know it's one don't
repeat yourself but also if it's already
been done don't redo it again it's like
you know Java you know you do it once
and you share it with everybody right
and so that's really how Django works
though even like with flask for example
there's a ton of add-ons like comes
empty but there's a ton of add-ons just
like WordPress comes with it's just like
a freaking blog right but you can
download a bunch of extensions and stuff
so I might eventually cover a
development with flask and a few others
but really Django is the most inclusive
one and probably the best documented one
mostly just because a lot of people use
it right so it's one of those
self-fulfilling prophecies you know so
anyway with that now that you know the
background there let's hop into
installing Django so what you'll first
want to do is head over to your favorite
internet browser which by now ought to
be Google Chrome and what you're going
to do is just I would just search for
Django Python or something like that the
website right now is Django project comm
so you just click on that wait a second
get take there this is the Django
website now
Django um you're a web framework I just
wish this website looked better
I realize it's mostly just an
informative website I don't know if
you've got if you guys you know do a lot
of web searching but a lot of times
you'll arrive on like websites that have
this exact like green background it's
like affiliate advertising is all it
really is it's like cash parking anyway
this website just turns me off
sorry Django also Django what happened
to your original logo in fact guys let
me pull up the original Django logo for
you guys because it looks like it's
nowhere on their page and yeah so I just
want to know I think they're separating
themselves from their original logo let
me pull it up so we'll do we're just
going to search Django logo and Image
Search here and obviously we get some
Django Unchained but okay this is the
original
tango logo okay it was a flying unicorn
okay
it was pretty it was pretty badass and
for whatever reason they've decided to
move away from this so I don't know
personally I don't understand it I think
it was really professional but anyway
that's what this is what you're working
with guys you're working right alongside
this little flying Pony unicorn thing
anyway so with that let's go back over
to Jango and what we want is to go ahead
and download Jango now depending on when
you're watching this it's probably um oh
this is an interesting link thanks Jenga
uh-huh this is what you want now the
time I mean making this this 1.5 is the
most recent stable version that you can
download like the development version
and stuff like that but for now
I'm just gonna say to everybody download
the stable version so I'm gonna download
this and wait a second I've got like a
few other downloads running so it's
probably gonna go really slow but
actually I've talked us through the
entire download so once you've
downloaded tar.gz
in fact since I'm on this computer I
don't even think I have 7-zip so to open
this up we're going to want to pop on
over here and down the 7-zip so we can
take care of this I hate seen it now by
the way I don't know if you yell gone
through the little downloader but I
think like people can upload stuff to
seen it and decide if they want to use
that the CNET downloader but it comes
with a bunch of like spyware and stuff
like that's really lame seeing that used
to be a pretty safe place to download
stuff now this one's not gonna come with
her download maybe they're done with
that down that was pretty lame for
awhile I bet a lot of people were angry
about that I love 7-zip if you don't
have any way to open up a target GD file
sorry that probably kicked me off
because there's some sort of admin stuff
anyway you should download 7-zip if you
don't have any sort of way to extract
that tar.gz file so I just went ahead
and installed it real quick and it looks
like I've got it now yeah so once you've
installed it that's what 7-zip is going
to look like so let me
take this Django and I'm just gonna
throw it onto the desktop and I wonder
if I can just open it yeah um so now
I'll just go to open I guess we'll do it
this way
[Music]
users each desktop can go extract okay
so now we've extracted that to the
desktop
sure enough it's here usually let's see
if we've got it yeah and then we've got
this tar ball in the distributed file so
we'll just go ahead and take care of
that as well
stri okay and it looks like this is what
we want right here what if I can just
drag it over yep okay so I just drag
that onto the desktop and let me open
that up and see if that's what we want
now in Django and we have a sub top he Y
lovely okay so we'll close out of this
and let me minimize this let me drag
this bad boy over okay so here it
probably pretty hard to see it on this
background okay so here's our Django
file now when we open it up the first
thing I want to do just to make it easy
whenever I go to find it we'll just
rename it to Django open it up and
rename this one to Django as well I
don't think I capitalized either one of
them and make sure yeah okay and then
within here what we eventually want to
get to is to set up that py file but to
do that if you haven't already added
Python to your path you won't be able to
do this next step so let me show you how
to add Python to your path if you have
not go ahead and oops this is not where
I want to be go into your system
settings so you know there's like a
million ways to do that you can go to
control panel system and then system and
I think we want Vance system settings
eventually you want to Rive at system
properties the next thing you want to do
is open up environment variables so I'll
click that and then under system
variables click down down down until you
get to path and what you want to do is
edit that path and go to the very end of
that path where you see here I've got
Python 27 and I've also got Python and
scripts this right here is what you need
to add to the end of your path it's two
paths
really we've got C : um backslash Python
27 or wherever your Python directory is
and then also add C colon backslash
Python 27 scripts this just makes it so
when you go to launch something with
python like from your command prompt for
example this makes it able to happen so
with that once you've done it just you
know hit apply and okay and all that and
we'll close out of our persistent
properties and now let's pop over to a
command prompt surely you know how to
get to your command prompt but just type
in CMD in your search thing if you don't
know and now so I'm on see users H and I
put Jango on my desktop so I'm at CD in
the desktop CD into the Django folder
and then as you can see it's django
django so i'm going to CD into django
one more time and now i'm in there and
there's my set up top P Y so now what I
want to do is do Python set up set up
that py and then install hit enter and
zoom goes a bunch of installation and we
wait and it looks like we're done now so
hopefully when we go to a command line
for Python now this isn't cmd.exe this
is a Python command line to test our
install let's import Django and if it
doesn't scream at you you've done
everything right